a sua lídia eu sou da mesma cadeira
eu sempre tive muita curiosidade de
saber como é que faz o ovo pochê muita
curiosidade é uma coisa que eu gosto
bastante e algumas semanas atrás eu me
propus a aprender a fazer o peixe
eu fiz o que todo mundo faz vai até
internet busca um tutorial um vídeo que
tinha a fazer e eu achei excelente
porque eu aprendi duas vezes que
assistir eu já aprendi que é muito
simples assim não sei se vocês já
tentaram mas é você põe uma água para
ferver e aí quando ela começar a ferver
você põe três colheres de azeite pode
portanto se você preferir uma pitada de
sal é você para uma concha dessas de
macarrão para você poder quebrar o ovo
dentro e aí você começa a brigar vou
começar a ferver
você começa a fazer um redemoinho e aí
está a mágica do negócio fazer aprender
ou puxa que quando você começa a fazer
aquele redemoinho né bem perfeito
enquanto ela está fazendo você pega
aquele ovo está na coxa e se joga bem no
meio do redemoinho e aí todo aquele
redemoinho pega gema enrola pega clara
enrola gema e faz aquela bolinha
bonitinha que a gente vê quando chega no
pato com aspargos presunto cru e tal e
aí ficará ridículo
ali negócio atual por você
ninguém faz todo o trabalho pra você foi
tranquila ótimo bom em uma mesa de bar
estava conversando sobre culinária sobre
receita e tal aí eu falei gente eu
aprendi a fazer vou puxar essa semana aí
pessoal sério nosso do mar e tanto para
aprender quanto você pegou o vídeo
errado ou a receita errada porque cara
muito simples porque pega água verde pv
3 colheres a tal facto redemunho lance
está no redemoinho joga no meio o
trabalho feito a eles mas você já fez eu
não fiz mas gente é muito tranquilo
entendeu
bom eu decidi fazer o ovo pochê neto
mais amigas que eu recebi semana passada
em casa e falei bom vão votar o vídeo
ali só por precaução é a palavra
a brigada tem de produzir é bonita e
acho bom
aí é resolvi fazer chamei meus amigos e
meninas vão fazer um ovo pochê que eu
aprendi semana delicioso tal igualzinha
àquela receita naquele restaurante que a
gente vai e nem vamos a pagar mais caro
para começar um negócio próprio de fazer
beleza bom
outro vídeo ali comecei a fazer voltei
agora pra ferver
como só fui ver neve na guiné-bissau tal
só queria te esqueci de quebrar o ovo
dentro da concha e aí eu parasse em um
redemoinho eu perdi o time da água e aí
vamos começar a ferver e quando quebrei
vovô coxa eu vi que o meu não cabia da
minha coxa e ele vazou para fora e teve
que usar um copo e eu queria mostrar pra
vocês um pouco no resultado desse
trabalho que eu me metia fazer então é
esse resultado é realmente não deu certo
ponto cabeça estão sabotando
agora vai
aí a carta que você fazer redemunho que
deveria ser a coisa mais fácil de fazer
tem que pagar então já o ovo pochê show
a fazenda 2
duas pessoas tentam reduzir mais pelas
bordas da vitalmed a quente
não tem a ver com um anel quem sim é ele
que ao contrário ele avisa que o jogo
eles fecharam vários já o meu cavalo ao
processo
eu não vou mentir
dom e é um pouco sobre esse tipo de
experiência eu queria contar pra vocês
que existe e se formou no mundo existe
na base da tentativa e erro
eu sinto informar você mas o mundo é um
lugar completamente sem planejamento
a gente sabe se é uma ideia que está
perfeita na nossa cabeça ela realmente
funciona
a gente precisa praticar ou seja a gente
precisa fazer e eu acredito muito nisso
que a melhor forma de a gente aprender
alguma coisa é fazendo é aprender com a
experiência é viver aquilo que a gente
quer aprender
eu trouxe essa frase aqui do aristóteles
porque estava procurando nas minhas
pesquisas pesquisa sobre o tema no milan
me by doing ea gente tem isso como um
novo conceito de aprendizagem né
uma nova vertente um novo jeito a gente
prender mares potter está falando disso
há algum tempinho atrás né
o melhor jeito então de aprender antes
de você alguma coisa que você quer fazer
esse primeiro faz ela pra vc aprendeu
mesmo porque o poder o que é muito
interessante pensar porque a nossa
natureza enquanto humanos é aprender com
a experiência por exemplo a gente aqui
ou você tem filhos não sei mas a gente
não aprendeu com os nossos pais através
de uma série de palestras como é que a
gente joga bola como é que a gente anda
de bicicleta como é que a gente come se
senta comportadamente na mesa
dependendo até sinepe realmente dá uma
palestra para explicar como ele se
comporta mas é nesse caso não há então
pra mim o poder de aprender fazendo ele
está aí tá na autonomia do processo
porque depende de você viver a
experiência para dizer se você aprender
ou não não precisa um terceiro dizer
agora
aprendeu como a gente conhece como a
gente viveu durante muitos anos dentro
da escola né
ah e é isso que a gente faz e que a
gente acredita na mesma cadeira que é
onde eu trabalho
a gente acredita que o melhor jeito de
resolver os problemas e aprender como se
resolve os problemas
é que ando soluções para eles é fazendo
e a gente faz isso de uma forma muito
simples na nossa cabeça a gente monta
mesas de trabalho onde a gente tem um
briefing que é o nosso objetivo do
trabalho daquele dia a gente tem um
grupo selecionado de profissionais que a
gente acredita que a gente precisa ter
as habilidades certas ao redor da mesa
pra poder resolver aquele problema ea
gente tem um tempo curto de trabalho que
são cinco dias
então a gente passa muito tempo fazendo
essa curadoria de pessoas para que a
gente consiga entregar tudo isso em
cinco dias e eu trouxe aqui pra vocês um
vídeo que mostra um pouco do espírito do
que acontece em uma mesa dessas que a
gente faz até porque eu descobri que
quando é quando alguém me pergunta que
eu faço a minha vida né
o trabalho tal é sempre bom ser um vídeo
pequeno almoço de casa demorou 45
minutos para descobrir um vídeo resolve
muitos problemas
eu escolhi aqui é muito legal óbvio que
há uma mesa da casa uma das mesas mais
legais que a gente fez foi kobe bryan
eles mostrou ele nos trouxe um problema
que era como é que engaja crianças de 6
a 12 anos a no esporte aqui no brasil
então o mais importante você entender um
pouco da experiência
chique né
vai ver é o mas eu gostei muito real de
poder contar pra vocês o que foi que a
gente criou eu sei que sou uma
sacanagem mas não posso que ainda que o
inicial mas preciso momento que a gente
está aqui hoje o mais interessante é
vocês entenderem e ver a reação do clube
quando ele viu que a gente entregou lhe
um beijo
rio o óleo o que o clube viu ali e por
isso essa reação dele é porque ao invés
de uma apresentação sobre a solução que
a gente criou a gente mostrou um
protótipo da ideia que a gente tinha que
são protótipos protótipos são a
representação concreta de uma idéia é
algo que está é trazer à habitação em
forma de pensamento desenho discurso
prática algo que você pode pegar mexer
experimentar e ver como funciona mas os
protótipos eles não são uma
representação perfeita dessa ideia eles
nem nem devem ser eles nem nascem para
isso porque eles nascem para ser
evoluídos eles nascem para ser
descartados
eles não se prevê uma ideia melhor do
que você imaginava
e aí você está se perguntando pra que
serve então protótipos os protótipos
servem para a gente aprender e para
provar para todo mundo que a gente
aprendeu e entendeu como se resolve um
problema e mais pra gente perder a perto
de perder o medo de saber se aquela
ideia que está perfeita não é saber se
ela realmente funciona
a gente tá vivendo no mundo hoje onde os
dilemas são novas e consequentemente os
problemas também são novos
então não dá mais pra gente usar as
mesmas respostas e as mesmas soluções
para resolver novos problemas pra gente
saber como é que vai ser o futuro
as coisas a gente precisa e desenhando
esse futuro é toda vez que a gente abra
uma mesa a gente diz que a gente está
ali pra chegar em uma solução e não a
solução porque também nesse mundo que a
gente vive hoje não existe mais uma
solução única perfeita e notável para um
problema que é o que a gente precisa é
entender que especificava posso ir à
escola
já estou sabendo que esse vídeo não vai
proteger global mas tudo bem o problema
ali bem essa parte muito boa porque
quando a gente já somem na verdade é que
a gente não é que não existe uma
resposta certa única para o problema a
gente encontra muito mais coragem e
curiosidade pra se arriscar e criar
porque as pessoas já não ficam mais
tempo agarrados às suas idéias é
tentando convencer umas às outras de que
aquela melhor o que acontece é uma
fidelidade coletiva com o objetivo
daquele trabalho com o problema que a
gente precisa resolver porque aquele
problema realmente importa as pessoas
que estão ali eu meu trabalho é buscar
métodos e ferramentas para as pessoas
poderem trabalhar juntas e durante boa
parte da minha vida profissional né
encontro pessoal que desenha
metodologias é poder fazer com que as
pessoas trabalham juntas e aí eu passei
muito tempo utilizando as primeiras
partes do meu orkut shop para poder
fazer com que as pessoas se importassem
com que a gente tinha que fazer ali a
fazer com que as pessoas realmente
colaborassem e eu descobri que não há
metodologia melhor do que um problema
real do que algo que as pessoas
realmente se importam estejam a fim de
fazer e porque fazer na verdade leva
naturalmente as pessoas a colaborar
porque quando a gente faz a gente fazer
isso a gente vai fazer é exigir com que
a gente abra mão das nossas certezas
para que a gente possa criar juntos é
entender que a gente vai conseguir
chegar
algum lugar se a gente jogar um
inesperado
hum pra mim então a gente monta mesas
a gente cria espaços seguros para se
dizer não sei onde
a resposta não sei não é um problema e é
interessante porque é realmente quando
você assume que não tem essa resposta
que você nós num seguro está tomando
negócio uma colinha desculpa
bom vou tentar retomar aquele desculpa a
fazer exige que a gente abra mão da
nossa certeza faz com que a gente
entenda que a gente só vai conseguir
chegar em algum lugar se a gente jogar
no esperado e fazer coloca foco no que é
realmente importante muito diferente de
quando a gente está planejando que
planejar é trabalhar com adivinhação
eu acredito que é um pouco é por causa
de tudo isso que as empresas têm chamado
a gente para trabalhar porque aos poucos
elas estão entendendo que não dá pra
passar tanto tempo mais planejando as
mudanças que vocês que eles querem fazer
gasta-se muito tempo e muito recurso
planejando ea hora que de começar a
fazer realmente demora muito pra chegar
o que acontece é que muitas vezes lá na
frente eles pedem um time do que eles
criaram ou eles tomou um tombo porque
eles percebem que o que eles imaginavam
com uma solução perfeita para um
consumidor para as pessoas realmente
funcionava e aí para mover-se navio no
meio da tempestade
gasta se muito mais dinheiro e muito
mais recurso
por isso que tem um protótipo na mão e é
muito e é isso que a gente queria dentro
da mesa ajuda muito a empresa
aaaah com a relação sobre as decisões de
futuro que eles vão tomar porque eles
conseguem enxergar que é possível
entregar alguma coisa a fazer
aproximar as empresas do futuro faz com
que elas estejam lá na frente o jogo
esteja nesse lugar de alguma forma no
futuro perde esse lugar misterioso e
desconhecido e passa a ser um lugar
tangível é possível e eu acredito que é
isso que faz com que ela seja mais tenho
mais coragem para inovar e aí pra provar
um pouco nessa minha teoria de que a
presença fazendo é realmente melhor que
nenhum eu queria mostrar pra vocês como
vocês que se todos os lights de mostrar
o meu última tentativa de ovo pochê que
foi essas passam por dia nós é isso
muito obrigada